okay yeah so I got I got called for this
nine o'clock last night
and fortunately retired or semi-retired
guys who have lots of old slides are
good targets for such things okay
so so here's a here's my usual history
slide again this is all pretty standard
stuff if you're watching this on video
you want to look go look and get the
actual slides these were not designed to
show up on TV screen sorry okay so
basically I spent a bunch of time at
Bell Labs this is my license plate here
in California right came out here Bell
System was breaking up I saw the light
and you know bedtimes ahead huh was it
partner
no no no just you know it's time to move
okay came out here was that convergent
technologies got recruited by Hennessy
and company to go over to MIPS and a
bunch of stuff there form spec been in
hot chips for a long time
we got acquired by Silicon Graphics so I
was doing computer architecture and chip
things and software and things and
actually about 1994 started using the
Big Data term and I'll explain how about
got started and where it fit and and all
that sort of thing I actually got it to
be an SGI marketing terminal show you
some examples and these days I'm sort of
half retired I still do some consulting
but I do advisory stuff and I'm a
trustee to Computer History Museum which
is useful because I can scarf up slides
and things and I rest time I mess around
okay all right so I I sort of forgotten
about this but I got this call from a
writer for The New York Times who's been
backtracking where big data came from
and he says so I've been looking for
this and it sounds like you might have
had something to do with this you know
all right and I said well yeah okay all
right and so I said you know it's not
like you invent anything especially so
so simple big deal okay right but what I
did do is spend what time popularizing
it within the high performance community
in some other other places right and it
was this sort of simplest thing that I
could think of
or describing a data pushing an analysis
that was on the edge of what was was
practical night we all sort of already
had big graphics and big compute but
some of the problems are really big data
and neither are the other two right okay
so anyway that's sort of where it came
from that's where the article is and if
you look at the Wikipedia talk page on
Big Data
I sort of added some detail in there
okay now people would ask has my
definition of big day to change they'll
talk about that I'll go through some of
the history talked about a little bit
how we got here and where I think we are
now and a little bit of where I think
things might go and at plane time for QA
so my definition hasn't really changed I
always thought big data was hey you know
if it's kind of on the edge of what you
can do I'll call it big data and that's
a moving target right it could be on the
edge for a couple reasons but typically
if it gets a lot bigger than the main
memory capacity or it really stresses
i/o performance or it's got really
difficult real time issues with the data
and streams of data coming that that
that's where that's where you get big
data from or if it's complex and
difficult messy kinds of different data
that rapidly turns a a moderate volume
of data into maybe a big data problem
brutally fit you can't sort of stream it
if you have to do random access all over
the place but it's also again a moving
target at any time usually there's
something that's trivial you know
anybody can do it then I'd say easy yeah
you got some disks and you've got got
something that's sort of a standard
configuration and it can do the job with
pretty Stanford software and you get big
where it's you know you need a lot of
work and sometimes you're going to roll
your own and some serious people got to
think about what they're doing and then
impossible is I don't care if you're the
end what the NSA well whoever you are
okay right with infinite piles of money
it still just you know it's it just
doesn't make sense all right and then
this is a moving problem
course now I see plenty of old-timers
here I bet how many people here have
used key punches yeah well this isn't
exactly a typical audience okay right
you may remember we had a 360 67 at Penn
State that had a made of main memory and
eight Meg of large core storage luxury
yeah I know well I go back further than
that but I do I go I go hey come on I
programmed that Olivetti program a 101
with 128 locations okay right so come on
you'd be breaking great okay so
obviously all this stuff that's in cache
memory and a laptop these days beat
whoops okay but I observe you know big
data is really been around for a long
time I like to start back with these
guys so here's the Hollerith machine for
the 1890 census right because you know
the problem was that the government put
out for bids because population was
growing and they couldn't complete the
census processing before the next one
came okay right yeah okay so what this
ended up causing was you know it ended
up they could do it in a couple years
and of course Hollerith you know he's
not got these machines that are come off
lease how does he get revenue from this
and of course there's the punch card
industry and all that yes a shaving
blade says okay that was funny with this
as a few years ago I took a gang of
first-term Stanford freshmen in the
accelerated computer science program
well you know what these kids are like
they're 18 they've hacked C++ for years
they both wrote Linux machines you know
the type okay right but they've never
seen a key punch right okay and they
look at punch cards and they said what
did you do this yeah oh this is how we
wrote code no no nobody could write code
that way how could they were muttering
oh you know nothing how could they do
this right okay and I said wait to see
paper tape yeah there is
there's a person who's not sure no we
did not restore that we we have some old
machines running but not that one okay
well then you know we got this stuff say
1950 he punches sorters plug boards you
know this was code right code for the
time and this is what you did you set up
all this stuff and plugged in the right
things and I actually use some of this
stuff because I knew how to use IB ie B
print punch utility to sequence card
decks right so that if you drop them you
could sort them and put them back like
okay great fun then you know Big Data
hey about this time 1960s big mainframe
was one of these course 16 megabytes was
the memory limit right for a terrible
mistake all right
do people know why that happened why did
they only use 24 inch to the 32 bits the
reason was that the 360 30 which was the
big model was a bite at a time machine
and it saved a clock cycle to to do that
and they decided to make that addressing
limit for that machine probably a
mistake
anyway gee you could get a couple 23 11
disk drives each with 7 megabytes but 23
14s or 28 megabytes
mmm good stuff ok all right so you know
1028 megabyte drives was a fairly
substantive kind of machine at that
point right now we actually had to think
of a noodle snatcher which had 400 Meg
of random access storage and this had
strips hanging down and that you would
rotate this drum and things have come
and spread the strips apart and snatch
one up and put it on a drum and then
move back and forth and we do sometimes
when they put it back
it would have relaxed and it would Jam
them in there alright so anyway it was
it was a strange machine but it worked
now important thing right about then is
when virtual machines got going right
seven CP 67 CMS kind of a bootleg
project up at IBM Cambridge but that's
important right because later virtual
machines come back and they're pretty
important to what's going on now now
what's interesting is of course at the
time most people couldn't afford big
mainframe so there were service bureaus
kind of reminiscent of the cloud okay
all right but they just weren't the
cloud right okay where were the wars one
things that goes on in this time is at
each period of the history there are
stack wars between different stacks as
to which stacks of hardware software are
what people want to use and here the
stack wars were between big vendors who
had a complete bottom up stack of their
hardware their compilers their operating
systems their utilities and then maybe
there were some applications on top okay
all right in the 70s you know the IBM
370 actually got virtual memory that was
that was kind of a nice thing all right
still the machines weren't that big and
certainly many computers were not big
data yet but they were starting to get
rolling when I arrived at Bell Labs I
got my group got the second P VP 1145 it
had 248 K bytes of memory okay and we
supported 16 users on that which was
fairly exciting all right oh we got
these huge pdp-11 70s we got 48 users on
that if you can imagine and you know
discs are starting to get bigger and
that what was going on right then was
clustering too many computers to compete
with mainframes at lower cost right
let's say well microprocessor and of
course here's one gets Ritchie and
Thompson you know early UNIX machine
microprocessors were toys I mean wait in
that decade you know but anybody with
any sense knew that's where the action
was gonna be right you could see them
coming workstations got going but you
know the mini computer mainframe guys
yeah you know forget that right the
stack wars here we're often in
algorithmic languages and sometimes
operating systems right so they're world
wars over whether C would ever be any
good or you know was it PL ones where
the future was or ADA
or you know whatever you like don't
laugh API well I know APL was before
that right and and I'd like to use APL
but it was a write only language so you
know it was kind of hard okay Bell ABS
so you know when I was first well I
don't know if people remember what that
was like the Bell System was a million
plus people Bell Labs itself was 25,000
people which was pretty amazing the way
I would summarize this is monopoly money
is good all right you can do things
right first half at that time I was
working on this thing called the
programmers workbench which is the
version of UNIX that took it out of the
individual lab to be more the utility
thing we did security things and shell
programming and a lot of other stuff you
see of a talk ironically called small
was beautiful and other thoughts on
programming languages which is funny to
find in a big data talk but still is
okay right unfortunately if you look at
the description I did not coin the term
agile software right you're that big
data well you know Bell Labs did Big
Data then right we had a group in Murray
Hill building five who got all of the
call records you know the ones that the
NSA isn't supposed to get all of okay
these days right and they analyzed them
to death up there right now they had a
whole lot of rules around this about who
could look at this stuff but they
worried a lot about this both for
Network design but also for marketing
reasons I mean after all you know people
but Bell System would charge people for
$0.10 phone calls you know and give you
a bill with all that stuff so they had
to have all this stuff right all right
love second hip part he cost of a dollar
dude send your beautiful ten send you a
bill that would have itemized things to
ten cents okay all right anyway then
later I worked on a thing called the
loop maintenance operations system and
this was an IBM mainframe with triplex
mini computers for a reliable it's a
distributed data system designed in the
late 70s and the idea was the mainframe
ran the big sort of
static data about the phone system and
the that many computers ran the more
active calls okay right you know if you
had trouble with your phone the person
you talked to was hooked to one of these
things that had to be up right or the
public utility Commission's would beat
on you right and they would keep track
of lots of details right I mean this
classic big data problem with they would
keep track of things like what was the
failure that caused this trouble report
was it a squirrel bite was it
Mayon made problem was it gun shot okay
all right gun shot was only a problem in
the south and some of the West and Maine
okay all right okay name Knuth stuff
like this okay okay so I was doing a
back-end data mining system and there
was an offshoot there was an expert
system the first one done there that
transaction stuff went through this
thing and ended up in Oracle okay
there's the path there right this is a
pretty interesting gang this is a this
was a sort of aggressive development
group that always used new technology
but you could still get products out my
boss later ended my director ended up
later as the CTO for Bell Labs and the
guy he brought in to replace him was
later the Bell Labs president so this is
a fairly serious now that yeah there was
we don't want to it's gonna go too far
afield okay right but but I had some
cognitive I had a group that had
cognitive psychologists in it okay right
so one of whom was really interested in
expert systems and from the time and it
went off in that direction because the
problem was you could train cable
analyzers to use the reports from this
thing to figure out what was going on
and when they got to learn it really
well then they get moved to something
else and you'd start over okay all right
that was a pain so we decided we should
have automate it well you know what I
get really amused with the cloud I'd
swear every presentation ever saw in
Bell Labs had a cloud in the middle all
right now the cloud was of course some
version of the telephone system or a
data system built by Bell Labs or
something like that but the clout you
had to have a cloud you know I mean just
there was always clothes right now they
were actually trying to build a thing
that went under different names with
processing in a network in dumb
terminals at the edge okay and they
started this about 1975 I think they
spent maybe close to a billion dollars
it was too early to build that you just
really couldn't do what you need to do
and by the time they finally got
something to work of course dumb
terminals were kind of not what people
were doing anymore I have too bad right
too early but clouds were there all
right how about 1980s Teradata
people remember teradata okay right
there's a classic big data company
although they only started to call
themselves that in 2010 right and they
had been building big systems for a long
time and eight they would make very
unusual systems to to do data mining and
data warehousing whatever you want to
call it right okay and they went through
some interesting corporate things
because they got bought by NCR and into
AT&T and then back and spun out you know
sort of a tough time
okay important thing raid disks got
going over at UC Berkeley across the bay
with the Dave Patterson and company and
that was obviously pretty important
because it was getting harder to make
big disks cost-effective and making
cheap little disks work well that was
important so again maybe not called big
data yet but the signs were there the
stat Wars about that time where networks
you know there were a lot of fights
between decnet and and tcp/ip and other
combinations there were database
management Wars remember we had all of
these things fighting it out right
around here I seem to recall things like
Billboard Wars on 101 right when they
would fight with each other right that
nowhere unix stack version Wars
typically by vendor but then there were
camps of vendors all agreeing or not
agreeing I was jolly right then there
were the distribution wars is it like is
the action in workstations or
client-server or pcs or
I think clients are different
combinations right we went through all
that stuff right and then we got into
the microprocessor wars' where i spent a
bunch of years that was a lot of fun too
now what it's pretty clear is you know
by the late 80s it was pretty clear that
you should build bigger systems out of
out of more commodity microprocessors
right the economics were just too good
you could not go build one-off large
designs interesting that automobile
business seems to be going through this
right now
sort of when you look at all electric
vehicles and hybrids sometimes you can
use the same components in different
structures and it's a lot easier than
doing it from scratch so in 1988 we
started design on the mips r4000 which
finally appeared in 1991 and that got to
be interesting I'll talk about that
stack Wars also we had Windows systems
people with different Windows systems
and graphics interfaces and we got to
fight over that stuff ya know most
mostly stack Wars sort of settled out
and that's gonna be part of what I'm
gonna get to later okay now come the
1990s browser Wars though when World
Wide Web
all this stuff really got it going the
s-1 SGI machine shipped in early 1992 as
far as I know I was the first production
thing with a 64-bit chip in it the first
product out the door was still running a
32-bit OS alright but what we knew was
we had to get the hardware base
converted over and then we could shift
to a 64-bit OS alright that's a tricky
conversion later in the year the dec
alpha systems came out with 64-bit chips
and 64-bit only everything right
and some people criticize them for that
I probably would have done the same
thing if you're starting from scratch
with a brand new chip architecture you
might as well you know keep it simple
okay now as it happened this was
wonderful
because because unlike all the rest of
us who already had a 32-bit architecture
and then kept that working they only had
64-bit so they paid a lot of money to
software vendors to make their software
for a bit clean so they did the rest of
us a huge favor because they spent a lot
of money to make this happen okay so by
1994 SGI had big systems we had like you
know 30 to 36 processor systems running
a full bore 64-bit erics we could
support 64 32 users we could go up to 16
gigabytes of memory about that time we
had a really great of 64-bit file system
journal you could pull the plug on it
and terrible things wouldn't happen and
this by the way later got contributed to
Linux all right I'll talk about how that
happened later at that point it was it
was truly a really aggressive wonderful
file system and we finally got the point
then where customers could just
recompile a Fortran program and use as
much memory as they wanted and and you
know life would be good right if it was
at all portable and again fortunately
these guys that helped us make sure lots
of suffer which is portable but Fortran
you know the Fortran
folks were all chomping at the bit
because they knew they could just
recompile and and they didn't really
have problem with pointers and stuff
like that they were in good shape now I
wrote about this there's a article in
ACM queue called long road to 64 bits
double double toil and trouble because
it was and that showed up also later in
kakum right because it was a lot harder
than it needed to be alright I mean this
was a surprise to me because we knew in
1988 what's what's the most predictable
technology trend in the business it's
the size of dram memories there's a long
period where the DRAM just kept doubling
you know and you know if you did the
arithmetic you could say you know by
1994 a medium-sized server could easily
have more than four gigabytes and still
be in the same price range and if we
don't have some software ready about
that time and the right chips it's going
to be messy and those of us who've been
through before the hacks to get around
the inability to address all of memory
yet you know I mean the things people
used to go through and the old machines
for operating system guys were pretty
painful we didn't wanna do that again is
always painful for that okay now I
apologize for some of the fuzziness this
is from a video right that I did for
another entity and I had to sort of take
screenshots and things okay but this is
what I was talking about this is a talk
I gave a lot of the times this is sort
of my vanilla talk for a general
audience right and this is where I
started using the big data the idea was
okay what do we do at SGI people have a
lot of data coming at them or they want
to create it and they want to get
insight from it what do you need well
you need graphics you need good fast
chips you need multi processors digital
media you need good human interface and
you better have good i/o all right to
move all this stuff around right so
that's when I sort of started using this
and I used to give talks like this
saying here's hardware it keeps going up
hey another good thing is the amount of
costs that you have for the amount of
hardware but unfortunately I sweat wears
you know we're still release one wet
wears and you know we're not likely to
to be upgraded any time soon right and
the idea being that software's got to
fill in the gap between the good stuff
and the not-so-good stuff okay so you
know SGI was known for for apps you know
this see'em and design and research and
analytical chemistry and oil and gas and
fluid dynamics especially in animation
for the movies and stuff but the push
here was we had all this great
technology for pushing a lot of data
around all right
and my argument was look we do big big
graphics and big compute but some of our
customers don't care about that what
they got is just a lot of data they
don't do a lot of computation on each
part of the data but they've got to
manage a lot of data and we have these
machines with high i/o rates because of
the graphics we have 64-bit everything
so we're not up against some limit we're
making scalable machines there's all
kinds of markets we should go for that
are outside of SGI's normal thing but
certainly by nineteen
six big data was part of our marketing
message and you know at least some of
this were in other application areas
they weren't just in the classical
science kinds of things and you know so
that was a that was a logical extension
I said publishing in quotes because
publishing clearly at that time was
including the web and all kinds of other
things of digital media that weren't
just making black-and-white images on
paper there were interesting new
visualizations you probably can't see
this very well this is these are
intrested is a map of the US where bars
go up and down you have a slider bar by
a year right you would do things like
showing the average income per person in
a state and if you did this what was
really nice is you could see things
where some states suddenly change
relative to the other states around it
and just looking at a table didn't tell
you that so when you did that you would
see things like there's this period in
the 50s where Kansas certainly leaps up
relative to everybody else when it goes
down and South Dakota leaps up and goes
down right I been want to guess what
that was Minuteman missile bases okay
yeah it was is that that you needed to
have smart software to make sense of big
chunks of data that we're floating
around okay right and if you could get
the right visualization that would help
another one was a thing like a data
helicopter where you'd see your file
system out in the distance and the
heights would be the size of files and
if you saw something interesting out
there you could fly out there and sort
of look at it right and I'm not going to
show it but you actually have probably
seen this how many people have seen
Jurassic Park okay you remember the
scene in the control room where the
velociraptors are coming for lunch and
the humans would rather not attend okay
and the little girl sees the computer
and says oh UNIX system I know this
right she sort of flies around through
an image of the the locks well that's
this okay all right that is not in the
book you're in the ilm guys saw this and
thought it was cool so they stuck that
okay right it was sort of a joke okay I
used to talk about you know that this
was sort of the architectural things of
the call the classic being with latency
things noting money can buy bandwidth
but latency is forever right because the
speed of light is a speed a lot and you
cannot brought god right god okay
alright and I had some things about you
know so this is what we're getting and
this is where the ranges are of things
but unfortunately here are the band wits
for humans you know and we're kind of
low you know on this and we're not
likely to get reengineered and all that
implied was you know if you've got a lot
of data you've got to push it around and
do a lot of good graphics and things to
figure out what's going on because we
are not that fast I note for instance
that historically every time you change
how long it takes to get an answer the
applications tend to change okay right
so for instance if you start off with
something that runs you know about a
million seconds or so you know they run
for a long time you get the answers back
long-running weather simulations or
climate simulations were like this right
okay
when something gets to overnight you now
get things like electrical cad logic
sims you know that you want to run
overnight and see the results when you
come in the next day alright hey if
something goes here for an hour or so
that's not too bad you'll run it while
you're doing something else by the time
you get down to here you'll run it and
look at it and when you get it down into
here it's something you can use like a
mouse not you know if you have a mouse
that only responds once a second it's
not good it's just no one will do that
right okay so observation is things keep
doing this and the one that get down to
here then you worry about cost reducing
them alright but clearly what goes on is
some of the big data stuff is is you
know has moved from being a really long
time thing down to being something
that's you know pretty good here I mean
after all how long does a Google search
take all right I mean it's down in
turf and if you if a Google search was a
hundred seconds it would probably not be
used quite so much as it is okay well
anyway buy a 95 s GI a chunk of it had
gotten to all kinds of things and again
there's banks in here there's commercial
things they're running different
databases they're you know there's oil
and gas like we've been in but there's
financial folks alright so there's a lot
of things that no one would ever think
of SGI doing and they were typically big
data apps that's what they were they
were huge but they were big enough to be
stressful and they were using 64-bit
stuff and they were they were happy all
this was a moving thing that's a whole
different you know there's a whole talk
I do I used to do what that stuff
actually did it right here for eg 380
well specially then it kept coming down
in Causton and it got into the bigger
machines right yeah ok so so anyway
there was a lot of stuff that you would
call traditional big data companies
today but that was going on back then
now the issue was of course is it wasn't
using small cheap machines these are
still a hundred thousand couple hundred
thousand maybe half a million bucks
worth of machines so this was not some
random little startup doing it you know
that those those kinds of folks I showed
up here you know we're serious size
companies that were doing this right but
they were doing this same kind of stuff
ok so then here we were about 1996 these
were examples of folks who were doing a
big data and again I got our marketing
folks to be using the term right
oh so for instance I mean you know red
brick data that was called data
warehousing sometimes or data mining
right and these were business kinds of
things and these are
they won't these are what they were
doing and it's not what you'd think of
when you think of Silicon Graphics but
it was actually fair amount these were
some of the other examples banks you
know I used to go to Wall Street a bunch
alright and talk with them and they had
classic big data problems they we're not
doing classic super computer stuff they
were doing big data stuff this was an
interesting one Telecom New Zealand it
was a fault system and there was a
terabyte big fight with terabyte because
this was back when 1.6 terabytes of disk
was big disk farm right that of course
was quite a while ago right that was
that was a jolly fun thing we replaced
the Terra data at a much lower cost than
they paid for the machine in about a
month all right it was classic big data
marketing stuff just like you'd see
people doing today now of course we're
still a half a million dollar or a
million dollar kind of machine but it's
ok they paid for it quick and these I
guess I probably can't talk about yet
but yes I used to visit Fort Meade all
right now about 98 I was worried about
the fact that storage was exploding
pretty fast and it wasn't clear software
was keeping up for this and I started
giving this talk big data and the next
wave of infrastructure and I did one at
usenix and it was actually one right
here at Stanford for EE 380 from this
talk ok this was about that same time so
now that we're calling it strategic
business analysis didn't mean the names
keep changing the underlying
technologies change some and what people
were trying to do was still the same
stuff but the names labels kept changing
right and and these were the kinds of
applications people saw interesting
things like fraud detection are ones
that are great because you have streams
of data there's sort of a real-time
response kind of thing all right the
kind of thing that you know that causes
visa to call you up 30 seconds after you
use a credit card in an odd place and go
oh yeah I was this okay right okay well
it matters right and that's nice huh
high velocity data a lot of data and
there it's a turns out to be good
application and I have we sold to a lot
of those and he were the kind of
customers there again what you see is
just lots of commercial customers of one
kind or another so let's say just not
what you expect but what was going on
and I will skip that okay so how about
today well let's see what's happened
recently
you know Beowulf Technical PC clusters
you remember that going I mean that
wasn't really big data exactly was more
was more how do you get cheap compute
cycles at first it was kind of held back
by the fact it took so long to get
64-bit x86 chips right I mean this to me
was I understand how the market you know
that wasn't the focus of the market but
it's in some sense for the computing
industry it's too bad it took so long
all right because the handwriting was on
the wall a lot earlier than that virtual
machines you know VMware and various
others right I mean after all IBM had
been doing VM for a long time virtual
machines really started to come back in
you've got companies like Google with
huge infrastructures and thinking hard
about distributed algorithms so now you
see MapReduce Hadoop all this stuff this
to me looking at it from outside this
sort of did what the for for the
relevant apps what the parallel
programming software did in the 90s for
technical apps because in the early 90s
we had all these multi processors at SGI
but they were not easy to program all
right caring you had to work at it and
the tools kept getting better you had
you didn't have to put as many
directives in you had Auto parallelizing
compilers you had cache blocking
compilers you didn't have to do all that
stuff by hand and more mortals could
could do it all right and I think it's
some sense what this did was it's sort
of just as the world wide web made the
internet more accessible for doing
applications compared to the old program
and you had to do for distributed
systems this kind of did it for the
database kinds of problems now things
like Amazon Web Services
sure looks to me like they remind me of
those 70 service bureaus I mean you know
that's kind of hey I don't want to have
the machine stuff myself I'll buy the
service from somebody else because
they're good at it and they have the
resources and I can expand my use of the
resource or subtract good right of
course open-source has really come a
long way and that's got lots of
manifestations going forward any time
there's a hardware discontinuity things
happen there's turmoil some of them are
pretty predictable I mean you know
Moore's law was great for a long time
all right I think it maybe still gets a
couple more turns but boy it's you're
getting pretty hard
clearly the clock rates stalled a while
ago which is why we've got all these
multi-core things and parallelism stuff
power and heat or sure a lot more
important we used to really not care
that much okay with CMOS guys used to
laugh at the bipolar guys water cooling
well you know you look at some of those
Nvidia based work stations with them you
know water cooling well okay right disks
keep getting more bits per square inch
but the band width is more like a square
root and the secret ation times are what
they are right okay so sometimes there's
predictable things but the effects can
surprise you I think you know Internet
of Things or wireless sensor networks is
something we're going to see a lot more
of right
and there's already plenty of it around
and I'm not sure of all the implications
of those crisp Easter did dust networks
and invented the term smart dust I got
him on a panel one time and another time
I asked he was on a panel I asked him so
you guys have talked about all these
wireless sensor nets and how good your
security is so like what are gonna be
the moral equivalence of spam and
viruses and he says oh well we've worked
on this and this and this but yes
someday your fridge will sell viagra to
your microwave okay all right yeah yeah
okay what can I say
right personal graphics people not
Vernor Vinge you know it's a good
science fiction author who's a networked
computing professor rainbows and is like
imagine
glass you know but everybody has got
contact lenses and people fight over
what reality really is sort of the way
Wikipedia edit Wars work okay right
where teens know what this is the truth
and they wish to impose their view of
reality on everybody else okay anyway
good book I want to Hugo that Ward you
know flash memory is more than SSD you
know that's a lot of potential there but
there's a lot of impediments like 4k
byte pages you know a really ancient
history from 360s and x86 and these are
pretty painful you know you talk to guys
who build build want to use flash memory
for more usefully it's a lot of work to
do all the right stuff to make that work
it's just painful it's also very rough
on memory management units yes I'm
saying is it's sad but true okay
in 1989 I demanded that the r4000 be
able to have a good range of page sizes
you can hear it with a decent hardware
structure for it because there was no
way in the world you could build a
memory management unit a TLB big enough
for the size of memories that were
coming okay you just couldn't write not
with 4k pages right and this is just a
continuing problem but it again shows up
worse when you have things like that
where you want to do something with 128
K pages as a chunk like a lot of flash
yes but you know I was I did the sort of
specifications for stuff like that okay
all right
Edie I just said look we have got to do
we cannot build a big enough TLB on the
chip when we just have four K pages but
it took five or six years before the
software caught up with it it's just
it's hard work I did unfortunately a lot
of things are pretty well stuck with for
K pages sometimes because it's in the
software like Linux is really yes oh
that's pretty important this is another
one where P like big data you know
there's all these people running around
like big data really it's the newest
thing we've never heard of it before no
I don't think so
right open source it's the newest thing
it just arrived I don't think so I
usually say it sometimes it started back
with David wheeler when he invented
subroutines for the EDSAC alright in
some sense but certainly by 52 when john
von neumann gave away the plans for his
IAS machine to anybody who came by
because of course you couldn't buy a
computer at this point you had to build
it so you know open source okay hardware
and software IBM share users group right
that was the technical users group for
IBM and people shared stuff all the time
back and forth right dicus got going and
of course one of the one of the ego
things was to write software and get it
on the dicus tape where they got put out
and people you know I mean it was
program or ego and reputation right you
know there was this weird hybrid thing
called IBM hasp okay remember yeah you
remember
okay so this was the IBM internal
spooling programs worked very good at
that point Hass was written at Houston
it's used an automatic spooling priority
system by IBM guys but it got really
liked by universities and research
places and there was this strange hybrid
thing where I BM would give out the
source to this and they would actually
take back changes that we made out in
other places and assist the director of
my computer center was Chuck Forney
and actually we get to get our chair
meetings and sing songs like two old
anxiety should old Chuck Forney be
forgot you know a lot okay but it was
very strange because it was this weird
mix of proprietary IBM stuff and
honest-to-goodness open-source with lots
of contributions coming from computer
centers all over the place right now I
was going on in the late 60s right okay
inside Bell Labs UNIX was open source to
all intents and purposes right I mean
you know when I started a release was
that you drove up to Murray Hill and got
on Ken Thompson's machine and saw what
was there and made a copy right I mean
that was released right okay okay now
then you know we got it licensed at two
universities on a Xia's don't call us
basis now the lawyers were not very keen
about this right because we had a
consent decree that said you shall not
be in the computer business and was
viewed as a concern if we got too close
right now ken Thompson and everybody
involved thought it was really good idea
to get this out okay right and I'm not
sure how this happened but he had a
friend who was in a hospital who finally
told the lawyers if you don't give us
Unix you're gonna see headlines in New
York Times people died because of lack
of Unix
and that was not true but it was enough
I think to push them over the edge so of
course this was a very clever ploy
because it ended up that UNIX sort of
took over in the Universities we started
getting to be able to recruit people who
already were pretty proficient in it
okay right and it ended up of course
wiping out a lot of proprietary
operating systems and the many computer
and other spaces then there was this one
John Lyons and remember that's a
commentary on UNIX
he took the Edition six research code
put it in one book and then did a
line-by-line commentary which was widely
used in a bootleg fashion by lots of
universities because the ATT lawyers did
not like this at the same time as we
bought bunches of copies for use inside
Bell Labs for internal courses
which was pretty funny okay ken was out
here at Berkeley
alright in the the late 70s which sort
of contributed to the 4.2 BSD stuff
right let's see around about here there
was the software tools stuff which tried
to get the UNIX software into a more
portable fashion and was a software
tools UNIX unit users group that shared
things around right of course
UNIX v7 came out and this was the point
where we had decided that we had to make
UNIX portable not across different
machines we've tried to move UNIX II
environments on the IBM MVS and univac
11 hundreds and all kinds of other stuff
and it was possible but it was agonizing
sorry said look we will make UNIX itself
pretty portable well that was pretty
bizarre then you know I mean that was
just not something you did alright a lot
of people like what portable operating
system of this site what are you talking
about right but it was right that is at
Berkeley Berkeley was competing for
complicated okay right it was sort of a
competing fork sort of because of ATT
lawyers I told you ken Thompson was out
there working with them okay
we often ran Berkeley UNIX inside Bell
Labs because we preferred it over the
version we got from the internal support
group sometimes okay all right IV so so
you gotta watch out there's sort of
competing Forks but you'd be surprised
about how many genes went back and forth
I remember and that was fine debating
which OS see the thing is it was a there
was a period here where in the 77 or so
Bell Labs management woke up to the
interesting pair of facts the first was
by then almost every project run Bell
Labs depended on UNIX in some way or
other and no two versions were alike
and this was viewed as a problem okay
right and so there was a consolidation
tried to go on right well inherently
look you know Canon Dennis and company
if they felt like changing something a
we changed something they were doing
research you could move pretty fast and
Berkeley UNIX was sort of like that -
okay right yeah you know was always the
question how could God create the world
in seven days
answer no installed base right and you
know it so things slowed down and some
of us for sometimes would say oh well we
may end up deploying on UNIX system
three or something because that's the
standard thing and stable and everything
but for some of our internal development
will use Berkeley there's something or
other because it's got better network
support okay I mean so so the thing is
people like to portray this is a big war
but there was a lot of stuff going back
and forth at you know it's yeah if you
see the diagrams the different versions
of UNIX that looks like a bunch of
mating octopi you know yeah okay
free software foundation came along of
course good news c and unix commands and
stuff that was good stuff and then later
you know linux and others you know tried
to redo it from scratch but things like
apache came up right which were a great
example of people getting together to
build something that they needed where
it was a better idea to do that than to
try to make some proprietary thing well
that was one of the ones that people
tried but it turned out linux did better
you know for whatever combination
reasons i mean we're a bunch of people
who reimplemented unix in some form or
other and this is the one that happened
to catch fire yes institution MIT was
incapable of writing a copy of colonel
so yes
gee you know open source exactly where
it fits in how has changed over the
years but is there's been a regular
progression from what's local libraries
to one machine
all right through mag tapes we ship out
in the 1970s to uucp the internet
webkit how about everything basically
it's opened up what sharing there can be
to lots more people and that can be good
or bad right I mean it's good because
you can share stuff it can be bad
because you can pick up say kind of
insecure software and embed it in things
worth billions of dollars okay which we
just seen right okay what you know
partly well okay so means it means you
know it's a different world it's not the
old classic proprietary if it breaks I
know I will call IBM and they will fix
it okay it's different mainframe stuff
it might take them a while but you knew
who to call it was theirs okay it wasn't
so this has been this whole big stack
Wars I think we're in for another period
of turmoil and the software stack here
and we got lots of different stacks
fighting over who's going to do big data
and distributed systems and things right
and you know it used to be the whole
stack was an OS you know a couple tools
of a few libraries I mean back in the
60s that's what it was right I just
observed a people if you're building
software on top of one of these stacks
think hard about what might happen
right and like are you saying that 1980s
of microprocessor choice it was like a
funny kind of Russian Roulette pick
which microprocessor you're gonna bet
millions of dollars on spin the cylinder
pull and wait two years to see if you've
killed yourself okay all right and I
think some of that like that now right
so as usual best technology does not
always win sometimes it's the
combination of alliances and who else
you get customers always help and then
the last thing where I'll end up well
know if your time questions is I observe
you in this business anything that gets
a substantial market lasts a really long
time you know longer than you'd ever
expect and so now I will go forward to
5,000 years from now that's from this
paper where they asked me to write about
lungi
scripting languages since I started
shell scripting and I said no no no
that's this is a more general problem so
here was Vernor Vinge from deepness in
the sky the the hero is joined a
starship crew and he's learning to be a
program or archaeologist that is
somebody who can dig down through the
layer upon layer of software and fix
things without breaking something to
starship to pencil because I've got
trillions of lines of code okay that
figs depend on right okay so what's he
doing cuz like he says the programs were
crap programming went back to the
beginning of time you know hey stuff
written 5,000 years ago before they left
early Earth
you know these things still worked at
the bottom was a thing a counter
second-by-second they counted them from
the time about when the humans first
settlers moon but actually is about
fifteen million seconds off okay alright
the zero second of a one of the early
operating systems huh
I recognize January 1st 1970 haha ok
burner didn't say that it's sort of an
in-joke
ok right he says we should rewrite it
it's been done it's been tried you're a
thousand friends could work for a
century or so it still wouldn't be
upward compatible and stuff would break
don't mess with it
this is amateur programming environment
ok and what I observe is you know the
stacks that people are using to build
stuff now have gotten you know deeper
and wider there's a lot of pieces there
right and you if you're gonna be
cost-effective to build stuff you've got
to use them but you ought to think hard
about what stuff you're building on top
of right so I you know all I expect is
over the next few years we're gonna see
a lot of churning around in what are did
big data problems for one different kind
of reason after another but I've seen
this kind of period turmoil before and I
think we're only just getting going on
so that's the end of the talk and if
you've got any more questions I'll
happily answer them it's generally okay
I mean I I fought long fights in the 70s
to get people to reuse code rather than
writing it okay all right and and and
Doug McIlroy started with that in 1968
at the NATO conferences okay we need
modules with good characteristics and
being able to find them and put them
together and not write code from scratch
every time and every language right so I
think it's good news that there's a lot
more there it's good news that you can
go pick up a lot of stuff it's just it's
different and you've got to be careful
and you've got to think about whether or
not there were good options in case
something falls apart so you have to put
your effort in different places I mean
I'm sure some of you folks grew up what
I did when you know you had a compiler
you had a couple little libraries and
you mostly wrote code well you know I
mean these days there's enough a lot of
stuff underneath so but mostly is I mean
mostly it's good because you couldn't
possibly build the things that people
build now unless you were doing it this
way it's just impossible for the
operating system piece offense I think
most of that class of problem is in
pretty good shape and the reason is
after all people were building symmetric
multiprocessor systems in the 80s on
micro processors
what I mean though is that certainly by
the 80s with people like pyramid and
sequent and SGI and sun-ok there were
there were a bunch of folks who went
through what you had to do to take a
sort of unit process or OS and do the
right stuff to make it okay for
multiprocessor stuff so the first part
was at least if you were running
independent tasks the OS scheduling got
better lock management got better I you
know it took a while but I would say for
a lot of applications the OSS got pretty
good certainly by the late 80s in
dealing with multi processors and the
fact that it happens to the multi
processor happens to be multi course on
that same chip and who cares okay right
even in the 90s we learned how to deal
with memory hierarchies like the CC Numa
machines where the access patterns are
not the same we got to know better how
to deal with cache memory hierarchies so
that got better now
what's still really tough is doing
applications that actually use the
multiple CPUs I mean because in the 80s
what we were doing was taking classic
technical apps where sometimes you could
vector eyes or vector parallel eyes them
pretty easy okay right and they were in
Fortran and they were happy as clams to
get you know a factor of three
performance on a for CPU system all
right
but taking arbitrary applications and
making that work very well is still hard
so yeah so there's more compute power
there it means it means if you've got
multiple concurrent things you have less
worried about having to do time sharing
between them because you got more cores
so okay so that part helps but if you
really want to get you know full
performance it's hard work it's also
very tricky if you look at the current
chips they do stuff like raising and
lowering the clock rates they turn cores
off so that they don't melt I mean
there's all this horrible stuff yeah so
as good a shared memory in some sense
between the the symmetric
multiprocessors it was equal access from
anywhere it's always the same if you can
get it right there next to the CPU away
this good and then you drop off the
cliff okay
separate to reengineer the network
interface to be multiprocessor aware so
that we're walking no longer slowed down
networks right never networking is
really ugly and bad right did a huge
amount of work in high-performance
networking and I used to spend a lot of
time trying to figure out what CPU
features we could do to sort of help
them out okay I mean the thing is the
classic microprocessor models I mean you
know networking IO is just ugly compared
with hey I want to do a disk IO I
scheduled it what it comes you know it's
a nice size it doesn't surprise me it
doesn't just appear out of nowhere and
suddenly demand attention I mean you
know it's it isn't doesn't have weird
buffer sizes and things so anyway I mean
look multi-core isn't question whether
it's good or bad it's here it will stay
it's extremely difficult with any of the
obvious technology pairs to get the
clock rates to really go up a lot okay
all right we got that for free for a lot
of decades right it's not there anymore
so what you get is multi-core now where
it really is is wonderful of course is
in the graphics turf okay right where
there's a huge amount of inherent
parallelism all right and of course
that's backed up now folks like Nvidia
sell a lot of chips for supercomputing
applications because with the right apps
you can get a lot better compute power
per watt okay all right in that matters
all right so you'll find big
supercomputers will have an x86 with one
or more graphics chips hooked to them
just because they give floating-point
computation rates that are hard to beat
for the right problems they're not
necessarily the easiest things to
program any other questions small things
like the Raspberry Pi and the Internet
of tiny things topic but yeah I think
the issue with whether it's Raspberry Pi
or the sensor networks or the fridges
that are smart or whatever is there's a
whole lot of extra data sources that are
coming all right
fortunately most in most those data
sources are fairly low bandwidth but you
start to look at things like the sensor
based off all the personal medical
monitoring and things okay right there's
just all these data sources that get
added in near big data they're not so
much you know like a 15 terabyte
oil-and-gas data set but there's a huge
number of sources and a lot of stuff you
want to keep and you got to manage and
it's complicated and messy and all that
stuff right so I mean I think that's one
more source of stress and I think I even
mentioned that in the 1998 talk it's
just there's a lot more sensors out
there that can generate stuff you you
care about so raspberry PI's are cool
little things and they may generate more
data yeah you know but maybe forcing the
little things that tend to have low
power requirements they can't send that
much data or they die quick I was
visiting a friend of the hospital the
other day and there was this machine
over there long during this part yes how
long do they keep that if you if you
look at things like cat scans and MRIs
and stuff data adds up pretty fast
you know just heartbeat stops volume
data yeah one day a volume data big
stuff you know expensive so the cost of
keeping the data is yeah you got to
worry about
and you know I mean the here's the cost
of processing graphics chips and
something help with that a bunch of
carry but but but you got to manage it
and remember that the medical guys have
to live under some really stringent
rules okay right that some of the rest
of us could just sort of big nor
I mean they've got lots of privacy
issues and control on that stuff and
hunger I mean it's its I said sometimes
people get earthed at the medical folks
for being really slow on technology they
got some challenges on that one the pull
off the medical with Amana switched over
to computerized suddenly all the doctors
say they asked that privacy who owns the
data oh that's the company that the
hardware what do you mean by that I mean
yes that's the fact that happen so yes
we lost all the privacy yeah well it is
not too late yeah well I have no clue or
whatever you know the guy there with
fantasies CS type knows what he's doing
but somehow I guess they never talked to
the lawyers yeah but almost all the
people they never software I fed them
high tech theory
forget about well Scott they've got
challenges okay what you have younger
ones a little him the older ones didn't
want those computers in there in the
first place yeah so can you comment on
the romance between the refrigerator in
the microwave
know that my microwave will still get
hot I mean you know obviously that was
humor but but it was there was the
general thing of okay so you make smart
houses with all every appliance being
smart and they talk to each other and
they adjust how much electricity they're
using and gee maybe the you know the
PG&E tells the fridge it said hey if you
can turn down here for an hour because
the power's tight right now Bob LA okay
right and now the question is is you
know to what extent do these things
communicate because of course if you do
if you do wireless mesh networks you
want things to talk to each other so
they don't have to send messages too far
and can they get in each other's Road
right and worried about that is that if
the fridge can order groceries the
fridge can call my doctor up inside
there's a piece of chocolate cake here
you shouldn't have that so -
you know this is bad okay me it's pretty
clear I mean look at the nest devices
you know nest devices are getting pretty
smart right okay and certainly I've
always wished for you know like how many
things in your house think they know
what the date and time are or at least
the time and how good are they when
daylight savings time changes of
changing themselves the answer is
there's a whole lot of things that think
they know what time it is and they're
mostly wrong right right well right more
or less okay maybe we'll have something
that you know figures out from the
network
time it really is here you know it and
does the right thing now you know part
of this point one of the cool leaves in
this book is that most of the computing
at this point is done by dust motes eyes
things that are floating around have
sensors and effectors and things guys
and the hero way back means to get his
own trap doors in this software okay
alright and he can get get clouds of
these things to recognize him and he
takes over some things okay all right
you know and there's software is so
complicating these test mode things that
the bad guys haven't been able to get
deep enough in there to figure out
what's going on okay alright so it you
know it's it's this case the Google got
there a long time before in what turned
out he said he always thought that if
you could get a trapdoor in something to
became a pervasive standard technology
you could rule it's one of many let's
see I don't know but if I did I probably
have to shoot you before archetype but
but you know at one point I did
calculate that the people know the top
500 list of supercomputers on your wind
pack basically okay right on a raw
gigaflops or teraflops right whatever it
was I calculated that the the most
compute power in the United States on
that was a warehouse in Seattle that had
500,000 Nintendo n64 games okay all
right now it had a little I Oh problem
because finding a half a million kids
you know to talk to each other was not
probably good but you know there's III I
have no idea if the NSA Center is the
biggest one compared to some of the
other ones that Google and company have
out there but it's pretty pretty big
I played all the video all the text is
the voice is nothing horse is nothing so
you calculate all the video they're just
possibly be capturing right and it seems
like that they the center is too big
they can store it so you should know all
right I mean I don't know how many
people dealt with the NSA CIA defence
signals Directorate but I used to okay
right okay and you know there's a rule
about disk space disks are either new or
full okay in some sense that similar
thing applies to somebody like like the
NSA is that if there's data to be had
somewhere they'll figure out a reason to
one have it okay right you know and you
never want to run out of space so you
plan big I mean you know okay
I mean so I don't know I have it it's
been years since I've had any employment
with that I mean yeah yeah and and well
okay I tell this story here so Ken
Thompson did a touring Award lecture
alright in this 70s or 80s 80s I guess
and this was about one of the first worm
programs right I don't know if people
have ever read John Brunner's book
shockwave rider okay all right which is
a dystopian future where the hero has a
worm with an infinitely replicating tail
that will seek out all mentions of him
in any database and change things so
that he's identity becomes invisible to
people very cool I read this book around
7475 and I laughed I had a cool story
but yeah you know and within a week I'd
seen one okay yeah all right we were the
only ones to ever find it as far as I
know is that Thompson put a thing in the
C preprocessor where if it ever saw the
UNIX login program it looked for a line
that said if if encrypted password
matches then okay and it added or if
magic password so if you ever recompiled
log in with this thing
you would now have a giant trapdoor in
your system okay all right and it wasn't
the okay so that was the first thing the
second thing is that look for itself and
it reinserted this code okay right but
this is back when when the software was
C was getting bootstrap so fast by
Ritchie that he would add new features
to the language and then he would recode
the compiler to use those features so
you got the new source and the binary
and went with it the binary could
compile the source but your old C
compiler could not compile the new
source okay all right so you kind of
have them both right so you never saw
this gimmickry in this source code
generator well one of our guys noticed
there was a function named in a binary
that didn't appear anywhere in the
source okay and I went and looked on
Ken's machine and found this okay right
but I don't think anybody else did but
they were exploring different password
schemes what the implications were how
much could you trust the people you got
software from yes it was you better
think hard about who you get your
software from okay right and the funny
thing was and the reason I wouldn't
answer this question with NSA if even if
I knew was I was up in the terminal room
probably talking to Kearney an or Richie
or somebody and kin and Bob Morris
senior looking but Moore's juniors the
one who did the internet worm you know
all right at that point junior was a
high school kid who used to come by
there okay Bob Moore senior sometimes
consulted for the NSA right and he and
Ken were sort of chortling away about
this whoa boy this was really fun you
know you know it really you know really
showed people don't read you shouldn't
trust people as much as they think well
hey you think we could put this over in
the NSA because they were using Unix
already oh yeah that'd be really fun
well below and then I think it must have
been Bob said you know they don't really
have a sense of humor so that's why I
would never answer that question
I do but they are actually some of them
some defence signals Directorate is the
NSA equivalent in Australia and I used
to go there all right I one year I was
there and we we I just been pushing to
get a Linux product lines into SGI for
parts of stuff that we couldn't address
and the DSD guys were hassling me that
they couldn't we couldn't ship them a
machine directly with Linux installed
and that was an era when because Linux
had crypto code okay it was munitions
and therefore we could not ship it out
so we had to ship the hardware there and
then they a local office in Canberra
would install the software DSD guy so
what is this okay and I said well you
know we have these rules in the United
States where we're yes this is
open-source software on a finished
website that we got but we cannot ship
it to you especially you know Australia
well I don't know about you guys and you
guys at DSD well you could be dangerous
well they had a good laugh I to go laugh
because I knew and they knew I knew that
they trade code with the NSA all the
time
well we couldn't ship them Linux
okay so I think we're about done oh well
it does in one sense sometimes it's you
know there are things that are
complicated software but then there are
things that were the difficulties simply
there's a lot of data to plow through
okay right people are doing all kinds of
different data exploration tools and
things at this point is that this is
where I say there's a lot of turmoil
because lots of people are having to do
things to cover the scale that they're
doing right so I don't know what I don't
I can't say this is the answer
but clearly people you know know that
they need better tools for this stuff
and people do it and you know I I think
better things will come out
you